[Music]
so let's start some first well thank you
all for coming thank you to data income
for hosting us so I'm going to talk a
little bit about how Spotify details
terabytes of data into meaningful music
recommendations and it works a little
bit about Spotify Spotify has over 140
million active users we've over over 30
million songs on our service users have
created over 2 billion playlists and
we're currently available in 61 markets
so a little bit about me I've been at
Spotify for six years now so it's it's
been a while it's been awesome I'm
currently in the engineering manager
here where I focus on data and back-end
have a background as a technical product
manager at Spotify and I start out as a
data back in engineer some of the
projects I've worked on previously was
radio our initial free free tier
discover page which is the precursor to
discover weekly I had switched off that
product uh before I became its cover
week Lisa Mustafa knew a bit there I
worked on Spotify running and last but
not least what not to recommend which
often is a more important problem of
what to recommend you could have a best
radio and then a Christmas songs coma
comes on or a song with talking in it or
in you know an intro and outro so it's
actually very very important to make
sure that you don't kind of get people
out there flow karaoke songs it could be
whatever so today a working us call with
a squad which is part of I speak for a
team called Inferno which is short for M
for knowledge
Spotify stand organized into tribes so
of course we have to have a Tribe Called
Quest Spotify like spawns and we're part
of the user engagement mission and
here's our mission statement the main
thing is that we want to we want to
present the right content
to the right user at the right time so
we build a lot of the underlying data
sets services models that teams like
discover weekly daily mix radio then
used to build their features on top of
them so we don't own any and the
outward-facing features so in February
2016
Spotify made a public blog post saying
hey we're all in with the Google with
Google's cloud solutions previously we
had had our own data centers we have
four data centers one of them is a Cuban
recently been shut down and we did
everything on our own on our own
hardware well we said we think it's it's
the right time now to to switch over to
the cloud and we went with Google
initially it was a lot about just okay
instead of having a bare-bones machines
let's just use VMs but we very quickly
started getting into leveraging the more
advanced technologies that they had so
Spotify has always been very big on
Hadoop using MapReduce we started
switching over to shield CEO is a
scholar framework that we that was
created at Spotify and it's open source
to check it out it's very very cool I
think for writing data for pipelines
we're also using Google's data practices
which is their hosted version of Hadoop
instead of hosting around casandra's we
said well let's let's have Google manage
got switched BigTable instead of
building up around storm topologies
let's use streaming shield which also
gives us the benefit of that it unifies
the streaming at the bash models which
means a lot more code sharing and
instead of storing everything in HDFS
you know let's store store stuff in GCS
which is Google's cloud storage pockets
were in bigquery so let's go so what are
we talking about today
we're gonna focus around four different
questions so the first question is has
two user hurt this song the second
question is just used to like this song
the third question is which songs would
this user like
and the final question is we have a lot
of audio what can we learn from it and
using these four basic questions you can
actually build a lot of features on top
of it for example you want to build
discover weekly you say okay well what
are some songs we think this user would
like but it's discovering so let's
filter out what they've heard if it's
daily mix we want stuff that we know
that they love so let's grab some of
that let's get some stuff that we think
they like and so on so these are very
much the building blocks they're trying
to go into a lot of features so let's go
has the user heard this song in this
case we're talking about listening
history is he keeping track of
everything that a user has heard this
thing has to be in real time we can't
have a server where somebody asks us Oh
has this used to heard their latest
Justin Bieber song and we say no when
they listen to it five minutes ago they
may have visited in incognito mode I
don't know we should say done but and
this is a lot of traffic which makes it
a very interesting problem we can top
out at over 100 K events per second that
we need to that we need to ingest so
what does this look like well we have
our Spotify clients they're all
connected to Web gates or access points
a piece as we call them which is
basically the main entry point into
Spotify from from the outside world web
gate will then push all these messages
into Google's pub/sub where anybody
wouldn't Spotify that is building a
feature can tap into so you can say I
want to hear when I want the band for
when a song has finished playing I
wonder when for when somebody added a
song to playlist I won't know weren't
for when somebody logged in was somebody
logged out and somebody registered and
so on in this case very interested in
when a song has finished playing the end
point of this pub/sub is hooked up to a
streaming shield job that we run in
three different data centers so Spotify
has has services in in three locations
in Asia US and Europe
for a fourth to minimize latency these
are all in Google's in Google's data
centers so we have this dreaming shear
job we take the take the data transform
it and write it into three different big
tables one in each location and off of
that you know our feature teams can then
call earnest in the history service
which we will freeze the data from
BigTable and this whole chain they might
have a lag of a few seconds so pretty
quickly after something has finished
playing we will be able to tell other
teams as far as I said I hate this user
has heard this song a little bit more
about BigTable which is the storage we
picked for this BigTable is a key value
no SQL system basis which means that the
basic building block you have is you
have rows and you have columns you can
kind of think of both as indexes you
know it's very quick at doing individual
or lookups or scans are scales among the
columns but it doesn't have really have
any other you can't put additional
indexes on it they can't do aggregations
for you or anything like that it's just
very simple but it's extremely extremely
scalable also one amazing thing with
Google BigTable is you can size it up as
down as your needs go so a default
BigTable when you create one is three
nodes if you want to do a huge ingestion
job you can scale it up to 30 nodes you
wait a few minutes for everything to
kind of stabilize you run your enormous
job there that's in there you might wait
a little bit more and then you scale it
back down again which allows you to
basically on-demand with why for example
where the Cassandra would be very it's a
lot harder to add and remove capacity so
talking to BigTable you says ERP C which
is Google's Google's version of RPC uses
protobuf it's very it's very it's nice
to use but it's kind of complex filling
out filling out protobufs
so Spotify has created a client that we
call simple BigTable client sometimes
we're not very good with naming that
we've open source that we actually use
extensively internally one very
interesting feature of BigTable that we
take advantage of is that you can have
multiple versions of a column so you can
sir just having your rows and your
columns you can actually stack multiple
values within a different column so we
take a batch of that and actually in
this case we only have for each user we
have users one row and we stack all of
its place and one column and the this
gives us very nice features where we can
say give me only data but it's certain
time stamps you know only give me the
last X number of X number of records if
somebody want to say you know what are
the last chance songs is used to
rehearse as hard
it also allows us to filter on their
field value and the columns so we can
send in reg access to say hey this
artist s column maybe this playlist and
so on
and offload all that air into BigTable
we store 90 days days worth of place
using up around 30 terabytes of data and
so far it's been it's been working
really great we've had this in
production 4x for five months now moving
on to see you select a song so listening
is not the same as knowing it's not the
same as liking if you've heard a song
once yeah you listen to it you may or
may not know it if you play the radio
two months ago and I said hey I know you
know this song you might say what are
you talking about I don't remember it
knowing a song definitely it's not the
same as liking a song so we try to model
what does it mean to like a song
well context matters if you add a song
to to your own playlist you said in our
repeat once you play it over and over
again it's a pretty strong signal that
you like to sound quite a bit you know
if you get if you get the song and if
you skip over it if you can't
consciously skip over it maybe you don't
like it as much
also how late how long ago did you play
it matters we provide data sets over
windows of 28 days six months and all
time initially we started out to kinda
like magic weights Anglet well if you
heard it in your own playlist you've got
multiplier of two if it came a radio get
a multiplier of 0.1 and so on which was
not very scientific so we actually early
this year created a survey that we sent
out to a couple of hundred thousand
users and say hey do you want to rate a
couple of songs that we think you like
and then you know it looked like this
they got a song that we know that
they've heard and we said you know what
do you think about it
and we didn't pick the absolute top if
you heard a song a thousand times we're
gonna we're gonna assume that you liked
it but we picked like a little bit
further down and we got some great
feedback on like much recency matters
how much does a song map up with your
normal tastes and so on so it actually
allowed us to to build a better model on
you know what it actually where place
should come from and how I should treat
individual place to model if somebody
likes the song so and yeah and the far
side is how we used to do it how we used
to do it in the old days all data would
be stored HDFS which has the Hadoop file
system we would then have a crunch job
which is a Java wrapper around you know
plain old MapReduce we would read up all
the data which could be dozens and
dozens of terabytes you would take
today's place and merge them in and
they're right at everything again which
pretty much means that every single day
you're copying 99.9% of your data
changing a couple of rows and then
writing them back again which was
extremely tough taxing on our on a
Hadoop cluster and now it's not very
efficient because data hasn't changed in
today's world using XI on BigTable as to
storage for the for the underlying data
we're able to take in today's place just
mutate the roaster I she's relevant and
I write them right and straight back to
big table using this is still a lot of
data it's over 200 terabytes of data so
we have a 250 node BigTable cluster it
this is still today for us quite big so
we're not doing it in real time we're
doing it back space like Calculon
daily which in this case we feel is
probably good enough if you've heard a
song a couple of times in one day we may
not be able to say that you that you
like it but if you've heard that you
know over a couple of days and so on
then we're more confident confident you
know we run some run some shear jobs on
top of that just calculating they'll
deltas and restore every just order
changes by which as the resource
utilization has gone down tremendously
with this we output the final scores to
GCS to bigquery where you know our
analysts can go to work or feature teams
often use bigquery data as inputs into
their pipelines and we also ship it off
to separate big tables in our three data
centers where services can do where we
have a service that can tell you how
much you like a song where future teams
can hit it in real-time which songs
would this you use alike so we can look
at we can look at this as two separate
problems
the first problem is a ranking problem
say I have a user I say I have 100 songs
or 100 playlists 100 artists and if they
can't put them in in order for me
basically put the ones you think the use
of a like first and then at some point
maybe tell me that everything below this
user probably doesn't like where's this
discoveries you say hey out of all the
artists that we have or out of all the
tracks that we have what are some good
candidates to give to this user we look
at these problems in the same way we
just think of a discovery as of ranking
from an extremely long list it could be
ranking among 30 million songs we're not
gonna return all the 30 million songs
for you but you know we're gonna rank
the head of it think of it back give it
back to you
so for this we need some way to come up
with distance metrics between songs and
users and and any other entity that we
have so in one hypothesis that we have
which probably it's not too far out
there as if songs often show up in the
same playlist they're probably related
so and we have two billion play
star you have created so let's just use
them so what do we need to do well we
need to sample some good playlists a
good playlist is a playlist that you
know has more than a song in it a lot of
playlists just have one album we want
some variety we want you know a minimum
number of artists we want a minimum
length we don't want to take too many
playlists for a particular user and so
on but we want up you know a nice good
sample we want to mitigate feedback
loops Spotify creates a lot of playlists
for our users we create discover
weeklies release radars we have a lot of
algorithmically generated playlists for
artists and so on we don't want to we
don't want to train on them because the
Lord and come from our own confirm own
data then we just keep feeding back that
say hey whatever you did was great keep
doing it and I cannot understate the
importance of not recommending Christmas
and children's music no matter what you
do no matter what people listen to what
happens if they like come Christmas
everybody listens to Christmas Christmas
music and that's a lot obviously a lot
of people play music for the kids but
then they still get very upset when we
put you know more on in their discover
weekly so how do we do go about this we
use scalding the MapReduce framework
running on running a data processor
between free right now see you yet I
just lifted it over to generate the
training data basically going through
all the two billion playlist we have
generating a smaller set we don't ship
this off to one single large machine we
let it run for a couple of hours on end
and it spits out a vector model that
gives us distances between individual
tracks albums and artists we get albums
and artists out Bible instead of and a
playlist is usually normally tracks we
randomly switch out every once in a
while the track for the album it's on or
the track for the artist is on and that
will be able to get all these three
entities into the same into the same
vector space
we don't roll up the track vectors into
playlist vectors today actually using
simple averaging that the playlist
vector is the average of the vectors
within it user vectors a weighted
average of what what the users recently
played so if you know that you know if
you're benching a certain type of music
one week you discover weekly will
definitely be different the next week
and we also provide real-time user
vectors which is very short term using
the listening history of service week we
had which if you go to a homepage on
Spotify you can often see that it
switches very quickly based on just what
you've listened to and then we we don't
make this data available in a multitude
of ways one thing I want to call out
this we call annoy trees which are
approximately nearest neighbors oh yeah
which is a nearest neighbor library that
we've created here at Spotify it's also
open source available on github
it lets you build a data structure where
you can throw in 30 million vectors and
you say okay I want the thousand vectors
that are closest to something so it very
very quickly let you pull out candidates
without brute forcing everything so how
does this work for the users well they
call in to a service that we call
ranking you know if they want to if they
want to discover among all tracks that's
part for more artists we call out to a
nearest neighbor service if they want
real-time data we call out a listen
history service we talked about a bit
before we do a lot of ranking of
editorial playlist if you on the spot of
our homepage there's a lot of
recommendation well okay here are some
playlists for you to jump into or you
know check out this stuff we call those
content pools we have playlists for
specific activities or playlists for you
know certain artists and so on because
then number and you know less than a
couple of thousand or I think less than
20,000 we just brute force the
calculation it's fast enough
and whenever we need the actual
underlying vectors we have a service
that you just use is backed by BigTable
it just give us back the underlying data
the content pools are small enough so we
decided to go with data store which is
done we don't really have to think about
how we store the data and anything like
that and it also doesn't sit on the
critical path so what can we learn from
the audio today previously we've just
used user behavior to model what we what
we create but there's a lot of great
signal in the audio you know we can have
acoustic similar to saying like you have
a song what songs sounds similar to this
acoustic similar is actually really
interesting to play around with if you
use similarity within the we call the
normal vector space you know if you pull
an artist and you pulls it in ten years
neighbors it's probably gonna be the
same genre probably if you know one
artistically gonna normal so the other
ones similar popularities and so on if
you pull supply acoustic similarity
chances are you've never heard of this
of these artists you know it doesn't
have any biased works popularity of the
items that you picked it doesn't care
how much about John Ross or language
anything like that but once you listen
to it okay yeah makes sense but it's a
it's very interesting experience then we
can also pull out there such as key
temple you know where all the beats are
if the song has silence if the sound of
speaking which is important for you know
not recommending songs to have too much
of that actually all of these features
except the first one is available
through our public API so feel free to
feel free to play around with all the
data we have we give it out for all of
our tracks here we have a little bit of
a similar approach we store all that
right there into BigTable we have a
shield job to detect new content coming
in new counter comes in daily on Spotify
we need to process it as quickly as
possible so that we can we can my
showcase shows up and
you know recommendable surfaces
whenever the audio comes in we put it
send it to a RabbitMQ and then we'd have
have Python workers that they picked us
up downloads the audio does whatever it
needs to do it could be acoustic
fingerprinting it could be here I know
just doing analyzing the audio figure
out where the DOM beats are and so on
and from there we we have a shield job
for generating the audio attributes
which are the key and the tempo in the
mode and the energy which is a mismatch
mishmash of all kinds of of different
algorithms and then we make this data
available and pretty much all all all
sources that we have as part of an audio
also helps us with a very important
problem which is the cold start problem
all the other sources we talked about
earlier requires us to have some data
until enough people put a new track into
you know good enough playlists we won't
be able to recommend this song which
means that you know when when Taylor
Swift drops her latest latest song it
can't go out right away you know we
wanted to show up in people's released
radar the next day so what we can do is
we can analyze the audio of the of any
new tracks that come in use that
together with some other metadata that
we know you know if we know about the
artist we have some data you know we
could look at the country came from and
so on and then try to try to map that
into the the standard vector space which
means that as soon as continents
available we're now able to recommend
that
so in summary here's a list of all the
holiday food technologies that were
using we start to heavily leverage all
the Google technologies some of them
like geo annoy and we do our own luigi
is a dependency management framework
that we also have open sourced up there
extremely heavy heavy users of and yes
so far the change-up has been great
completely switching over a platform has
given us a great chance to kind of go
back and rethink how we've been doing
things saying well do we want to just
forklift this over or a stepchild a
chance for us can I rethink how we're
doing it's opened up a lot of our
opportunities for us to do a lot more
stuff in real time now what she were
able to merge a real-time and batch
processing which has been extremely
extremely helpful and it's been a little
bit painful but overall overall it's
been it's been a great journey and that
was all I had thank you very much
[Applause]
any questions
listen to tables culture for your users
recently listen to tables you said you
have one in Europe North America and
Asia are those all this those replicas
or they only for users of that region
users normally connect to the data
center that they're closest to but not
necessarily you know we could for
example to take a data set it down for
maintenance or if we have any kind of
problems so we cannot assume that users
will will always be in one data center
which means that we basically any any
song that comes in we push it to all
three data centers a big table currently
does not have have replication between
data centers they're opening up
replication within within a data center
which basically means that you can now
have one big table for your service
calls and in a separate one that you for
example drawn your reporting on well in
our case now we have to be a little bit
careful when we run ingestion so
reporting to like to scale them up and
down so that we don't impact the latest
your services but hopefully across
across data center replication is coming
a big table and we will jump on that
when it comes thanks one more how do you
deal with is there a problem with
increased latency when a user goes
traveling outside of their normal
database region no Spotify users DNS to
find you the closest data center I had a
question for you over other site you
seem like you've made a big move away
from say spark your using spark as your
course or to run or other jobs on to
cloud data flow which I understand is I
mean I'm on Amazon so I guess I'm not so
I don't get to play with the Google toys
but based on an Apache project that
Apache beam how do you find working with
almost a completely different interface
or did you I from what I understand you
used Scylla kind of like almost abstract
some of those details away what were
some advantages of moving to say cloud
dataflow over just running on course
park so actually most Laura Spencer yeah
so so we were actually not extremely
heavy usage of spark beforehand we were
mostly using MapReduce I think the main
reason was that let Google handle the
management of you know workers or
anything like that
we do have a toll called SP SP Hydra I
believe that we've open-sourced the kind
of lets you easily create and tear down
Hadoop clusters but we've we figured
that no let's just kind of abstract all
of that away and she was written very
much looking at spark and at scalding
making the transition very easy for us
and I think so far it's been a very good
transition we definitely had a little
bit of growing pains but google has been
buried has been very open and open and
working with us
so the question is growing pains if
there's anything that we found harder
now than done before what sometimes when
things do go wrong it's very much a
black box so you know you're having some
kind of issues you know you know your
big table is performing erratically or
something you you really have nowhere to
go Google there has been you know has
been very open and kind of helping us
out and and there also have been
building more more tools for monitoring
and kind of looking at it but it
definitely has been scary but I feel
like anything we have a lot of data
Google has a lot more so you know any
problems we run into we're pretty
confident that they've hopefully already
seen
and for the you talked about the back
door space I'm wondering how you
normalize was different inputs like if
you have different attributes or
features or quality the the inputs are
just adjust a playlist on the content
and you talked about the mishmash for
different attributes between s via and
and oh sorry for that so that this is
just different models so for example we
have a model to to calculate how much
speech a particular song contains for
that is actually a voting between two
SVM's I don't know why they have to
devote but one for some others neural
networks so it's more each individual
attribute like energy valence and so on
are calculated by by different by
different methods so they're they're
independent thank you I am have you have
you guys thought about how discover
weekly may influence a user to move a
song into a plays playlist with another
song and then create a kind of feedback
loop and where the model is almost
training itself or influencing the kind
of organic environment you guys are
aiming good yeah it definitely is
something we think about because the
more people the more we help people
discover music the more music they're
going to listen to and save that that we
have so it's it is a problem or it's
something it's something we think about
we think today enough people create
playlists but as we're going forward
it's definitely something that we we
have to start thinking about more it's
like what other signals can we use to
not just get this feedback loop going
over and over
uh hi I was wondering if you could talk
a little bit more about your cold start
problems in particular not with just
songs but also your users like if you
have a brand new user how do you sort of
get recommendations out for him or her
and in addition you sort of talked about
listening versus actually liking and how
there's a delay between like listening
for a day versus listening for a longer
period of time um so yeah if you could
just address those so the course our
problem with you sir it's basically we
know nothing about to use we might we
might know or we may or may not know
some demographic data about them but
that's about it so often when users go
on board we ask them to go but they do
Spotify we ask them to a little bit of
onboarding maybe tell us a couple of
artists that they like a couple of songs
that they like our goal is basically to
get them playing something as quickly as
possible as soon as we have you know a
couple of plays we can now say okay at
least you've listened to these couple of
songs now we can recommend stuff for you
Amane um it may not be your you know
your true tastes but at least you've
actively picked something but then some
of our features are are created in a
batch fashion so some of the things
won't show up until the next day or
discover weekly and I might take you a
week to get so it is it is something
that we're actively working on like how
can we how can we get new use how can we
get great music from new users as
quickly as possible
so and the other question was around
again dude is there value in partial
place then there is value in partial
place we lit we look at skips you can
definitely have like a LOD skip and a
landscape the easiest model you can
build on predicting skips is to say that
the user skipped the previous song and
you're 90% accurate so we definitely
look at you know if you see just sits
and click lick lick lick lick lick lick
you know it may not it may not tell you
much
but if they listen 20 30 seconds into a
song and then skip away that may mean
okay they give the song a chance Sarah I
don't like it or I'm not feeling it
right now
so we say okay well that's kinda like a
little negative signal if they listen
through most of the songs through you
say like well you know maybe the song
has a long outro or whatever that was
okay that's good so definitely the the
length of time until the skip matters
quite a bit
so you talked about kind of the
identifying spoken word and those
aspects is there any kind of NLP or
processing on that going on for either
like you know this content isn't
appropriate for children or this song
has puns in it or I have a pun right
running playlists specifically and you
know how do you seems or tropes or like
other kind of things that you can get
out of the actual lyrics in order to
create more data so today my team we
don't look at lyrics I think there are
other teams at Spotify to look at it we
are more looking so now to just detect
speaking in a song to say you know if
there's too much speaking you know
should we get it out we don't do like
look for it look for explicit words or
anything like that we do get explicit
tags from the from the labels that we
use so if you yeah especially if you're
if you're a free user you know every
once in a while we have to kind of give
you another song but so we definitely
they're taking after countif all the
songs you listen to are non-explicit
we're not going to give you an explicit
song but yeah I would love for us to get
more into like the NLP part because I
think there's a lot of signal in the in
the actual lyrics
so continuing on the same topic the
learnings that you get our listeners
likability is this knowledge shared with
let's say music producers or outside in
the stream the music industry so Spotify
has recently launched a Spotify for
artists app that artists can can
download and they can kind of see you
know where their fans are what they're
listening to and so on I don't know
exactly what data we share with them
officially skip ratios or things like
that we're definitely giving them a lot
more data to kind of get to know you
know your fans are over here or you know
your dis popular in these these
demographics and so on so yeah we're
working quite a bit with artists and
it's just wrapping up more and more
[Music]